we are very excited about our next guest
she's an actor she's an author she is
Lauren Graham Graham as you know is best
known for her starring as Lorelei
starring role in the acclaimed series
that would be Gilmore Girls that series
ran as Tony knows for seven seasons and
then it returned for his special Revival
back in 2016. here's a look
oh Rory come on did you order from
Amazon again because we're gonna get
your books our own house I didn't I
swear it's from my mother what is it
it's heavy must be your hopes and dreams
for me I thought she discarded those
years ago
okay Rory and Lorelei over nearly a
three decade career Graham has made a
name for herself as an actor a writer
and a producer thank you very much he's
also a three-time New York Times
best-selling author thank you very much
her new book of essays the latest one is
called I love this title have I told you
this already stories I don't want to
forget to remember in it Graham
discusses personal stories from her
early days in Hollywood Life and family
Lauren Graham we're happy to say is
joining us from her home in Los Angeles
hello Lauren Graham on this day before
Thanksgiving
good morning how are you I'm good so are
you cooking are you eating are you going
somewhere if we were there now could we
smell this turkey cooking already what
are you doing I'm prepping I'm cooking I
started every year I try to start a
little bit earlier so this year I
started yesterday but I have lots to do
okay you can send us your address later
we'll be by but let's let's
talk about your book because Lauren I
love the title uh chapters the names
boobs of the 90s Ryan Gosling cannot
confirm and forever 32. I want to start
with forever 32 because you said you
started thinking about that when you
were 22 and you you wondered if somebody
at 32 they do they walk with their
shoulders hunched over do they have a
limp are they using a cane and now as we
sit today and we're all over 32 you must
crack up about that at 32 worrying about
what's it like
yes well that's sort of what the essay
is is how wrong you are at different
ages thinking about what the next decade
will bring and how lucky I am to have
friends of all ages basically
you know I also thought it was
interesting that when it comes to aging
and I never thought about this until you
pointed it out that only women are
writing books about aging you said you
Googled you didn't see any books about
aging written by a man
well I that's an essay called I feel bad
about Nora ephron's neck which is about
sort of an uh homage or just my love for
Nora Ephron and when I Googled men necks
aging what came up was why are men so
obsessed with women's necks so I just
wondered if it isn't a comedy that's
sort of uniquely a female
Tony won't answer that well I mean I
could write a whole book about how I
feel about my neck to be honest with you
because I didn't put enough suntan
lotion on it right I was playing
baseball so I've got some serious damage
back here I don't like side angle shots
but you know that's for a future essay
uh Lauren I love your tips on like the
high the Hollywood hierarchy could you
explain that essay talk about a little
bit
so
um I guess one of my experiences of
having been lucky enough to be in this
career for a long time is the endless
discovery of of
um language and rules I didn't know
existed
um and that essay is about being booked
on a talk show and sort of the the
unspoken behind the scenes of who needed
to be booked with me
um I guess it's just you no matter how
much you learn there's always more to
understand about the secret behind the
scenes
yeah there's self-reflection
um with a comedic undertone but then you
also tackle some tough topics you talk
about how you didn't have a relationship
a real relationship with your mom but
her courage allowed room for yours how
so
um yeah I was mainly raised by my dad
and my stepmom my mom lived in England
um but she was kind of an unusual person
for her time in that she strived to be
an artist she made that effort she was
quite unconventional in the way she
lived and while those dreams didn't
exactly come true for her it definitely
um gave me the idea that it was possible
and so I I feel very indebted to her for
that
you also talk about Gilmore Girls we
have to talk to you about that because
you said it changed your life for the
better I want to talk about that and you
say you're not going to answer the
question who is the baby daddy for Rory
is it Logan is it Jess you have your own
thoughts about that but you're not
you're not saying who the father really
is but talk to us about Gilmore Girls
and what it means to you and are you
guys coming back
um what it means to me is how incredibly
fortunate I feel to have fallen in love
with a part that then I got to play
um I I don't know how many of those you
get in a lifetime in a career and the uh
the fact that it has continued to bring
people
um Joy is very
um fulfilling to me and the fact that I
then have spent years and years and
years answering questions I can't
possibly answer like if we're coming
back or who uh what team I'm on
um I just love that the fans are that
passionate that it still is alive for
them but I can't I can't answer or it
would all be over for me
yes you could we won't tell anybody who
are you look team Logan team Jess
I haven't caught up with the latest
Netflix series I want to say people
should go back and watch episode one
straight through from the beginning
because you're such a good mom on the
show and Rory is such an interesting and
complicated daughter and there's so much
for families to get into and it's just
darn entertaining also I really love it
it's a huge show in my household so
thank you thank you well this time of
year it's running non-stop so you can
you can do you can meet that goal of
starting from episode one uh pretty much
a little family activity Lauren our
executive producer Shauna Thomas you
should meet her she says she's team
Logan if that matters to you it matters
it all matters thank you Sean I
appreciate it all right bye Lauren
Graham thank you have a great holiday
tomorrow Happy Thanksgiving everybody
thank you so much you too have I told
you this already is on sale now wherever
you like to buy your books